here with reaction author of the brand
new best-selling book The puppeteers the
people who control the people who
control America Fox News contributor
Jason Chaffetz
or senior advisor to President Clinton
Mark Penn Is With Us
by the way Jason I love the book
you know I find these positions
interesting of Robert F Kennedy Jr I
really do
um and one he's against biological Men
playing in women's sports I agree with
them on that you heard his comments on
the border I agree with him on that and
you know what whether you agree or
disagree with his position on
vaccinations at least he had the courage
to stand apart and speak his mind and he
had a ton of critics and I admire people
that are willing to go against the Great
yeah I know look I totally agree uh Sean
I I think that's right I think
compassion authenticity they win the day
you can't fake those things and and what
Robert uh what Kennedy Jr is is is
exemplifying is he's going out to the
Border he's talking to real people he's
holding his own camera at two o'clock in
the morning saying the the border is
broken it's surprise surprise Common
Sense actually makes sense to a lot of
people even some of those Democrats and
once they learn to read and write Sean
guess what they're going to start going
and going to people like Kennedy who
actually you know walk the walk and get
out there amazing how that actually
works no it is you know Mark Penn I I
look at this and I know you were
pollster for the clintons for a long
time and you I think agree with me that
the Democratic party is swung really far
to the hard left
um so far they've been able to sustain
it
um I think ultimately it's unsustainable
because I don't think these policies
work your thoughts
well I think that we're going to see
what happens with this nomination right
now because I think Biden is only
getting in my poll about 40 percent of
the Democrats he's got to improve his
numbers a lot of people think he has
moved too far to the left and so if by
September he doesn't improve his numbers
Kennedy moves up I think you'll see two
or three governors get in this race and
you'll have a real Democratic primary
all right so you agree with me hold on
can he do it who are the other do you
agree with me
look if I had Gavin newsom's phone right
here in front of me I would guarantee
you he's getting dozens of text messages
from prominent Democrats and donors
saying please Gavin get in this race and
run do you disagree with that and if you
and let me know if you do if not who do
you think the other Governors are
oh I I completely agree I I and I think
the governor of Illinois and governor of
Michigan I think those three governors
are poised to run in the Democratic
party maybe an AOC will get in you know
I think this could have really become a
wide open primary wow okay
um will the party going hard left hurt
them in the end
look I think the party's got to come
back to the center I think this budget
deal was a move to the center if it's
going to win the Democratic party's got
to move to the center and I think the
party that is in the center in this
election will be the one that wins all
right we appreciate it uh by the way
thank you Mark Penn and also uh
congratulations it's the new book uh the
puppeteers the people who control the
people who control America amazon.com
hannity.com bookstores everywhere Jason
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else